[Music]
there it is the fact that if your if you
go on Twitter you get I get a lot of
stick but what worries me more is not
the nut jobs on Twitter telling me that
I'm you know fat or ugly or stupid or
whatever it's the underlying it's the
underlying idea from the people who are
so afraid for me that I as a woman
cannot possibly hand all that kind of
difficulty that I must be shielded like
a child from that kind of thing that's
the more worrying argument the
patronization of people rather than the
actual deal of you know the fact that
even when things are difficult you can
deal with it I mean I keep using the
example of abortion abortion activists
do a lot of work on them in the past
fighting for their arguments women used
to get pelted in the street I mean
pelted and called baby murders and yet
they still managed to champion their
argument and yet they still managed to
win why is it that we women on the
Internet are not able to deal with a
similar amount of you know conflict why
is it changed exactly yes why I mean why
should we have to what why do we have to
die why do we have to live why do we
have to deal with any kind of it's it's
part of a personal responsibility as a
individual society to deal with these
also be things that in an analog world
if I get threatened with death on the
street if a man comes up and says it's
going to kill me on the street and I
stop the local cotton say Nigel here is
getting a bit aggressive I'm gonna we're
gonna have a really different great
we're gonna have a really different
conversation with that officer than if I
just say this guy on Twitter named
monkey one two three yeah said that he's
he knows where I live and he's coming
for me right and Twitter I'm sort of
right to Mountain View and they'll be
like oh god you live in London and
nothing will happen yeah right or
there's kids like these are it's I'm
with you I'm a free speech speech
advocate as well I also think these are
really we have to have a really rested
for what they tweet by the way well
that's right and so they have to be
different
caitli resent what you said about women
that you can survive all of this and
what's wrong with the rest of us
actually a really resented that's so
make your so unaware
of the level of abuse of the level of
intimidation of what that does to your
psyche now you might be very much braver
and stronger than me but sorry I am not
prepared to live in your democracy where
these anonymous cowards come for me hour
after hour and it's not the same as the
suffragettes and the people who actually
physically go out and and fight as
activists a terrible force and also what
about child pornography what about all
those vulnerable people who are now I
love the internet for all the good it
does I'm not a Luddite but I'm not
stupid about these freedoms actually
because it's curtailing my freedom to
sleep easy for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas her III TV
you